hey guys before this video begins I have
a really cool product that I want to
show you guys it's the arcade battle
pack that comes in pity Pi edition this
will fit on any phone here's me putting
it on so you basically have buns and you
have triggers and you have these comfort
handles I don't know if you ever played
like fortnight or well obviously you
haven't play fortnight but pub G on your
phone and after a while it really hurts
your hands with this it actually turns
your phone into a gaming console I think
it's super cool and the best part about
it here's me playing Call of Duty with
it you have such an advantage playing
with this I have so much fun I recorded
this very awkwardly trying to hold it in
front of the camera but I still won this
game it's so hilarious everyone else has
two fingers that you get to use while
you have four and buttons that you can
use basically me just drop shotting
people hit kill everyone it's so fun
they have other cool products as well
check out arcade games it's really cool
to work with them it seems like they are
genuine supporters of the channels which
is really cool as well I definitely
recommend this product Thank You arcade
for sponsoring this video now let's get
on with it
[Music]
boomers welcome on this channel there's
no discrimination against boomers you
have to understand that when you say
okay boomer if they're really hurt it's
a really strong insult this is trending
on Twitter this week okay boomer
signifies younger generations attitude
towards the status quo okay boomer got
them Gen see solving problems created by
boomers boomers saying Gen Z are lazy
and useless yes you are
what problem had gen C solved huh
goddamnit Oh oh my god this changes
everything
wait what year are actual boomers 1946
to 1964
well that is all changed for whatever
reason you're over 15 okay boomer my 13
year old kid and all her friends are
hanging out and calling each other
boomers a great time one this or says
something stupid okay boomer you just
can't recover from okay Boober it's
basically no you but you can't go into a
reverse card you just can't there's no
other option teen calls everyone over 25
a Boomer oh and God Oh God if I see
anyone posting these I'm calling the
cops okay okay Zener oh it doesn't work
okay Zoomer let me enjoy my energy drink
just because I'm 30 and like energy
drinks
there's always I hope this okay boomer
trend die soon I've been called the
boomer three times in the last week by
strangers on the Internet I'm 24 okay
boomer oh you never know when they're
gonna strike it's like basically asking
for it do people just stop okay boomer
oh that stinks when the hot end amigo
says it Oh
hurt really bad boomers kids these days
need exercise also boomers boomers are
fat remember that this is the war of the
Internet which side are you want hey are
you on the side that love really clever
and thoughtful comics you are watching
those whales son now Netflix that's
funny
what's the joke joke I'm not a Boomer ok
but yeah it's funny
see this is why I am so tall because I'm
not a um oh no oh god oh god
if Titanic seg today I mean what else
are they gonna do just freeze to death
boring you gotta save your iPhone this
is so cringe doesn't boomers know that
phones are waterproof now Gotham
teenagers it sucks when adults are
condescending to you because of your age
also teenagers when an older person has
a different opinion okay boomer okay
boomer my 86 year old grandmother
replied okay boomer to my boomer on in
an argument the future is now younger
woman Wow old people's phone starter
pack fun-sized huge good morning
wishing you a nice day hope you all have
a clever day lever day yes you can swipe
on it son you'll have to walk to the
next painting what kids swipe okay
boomer marks the end of friendly
generational relations now it's war its
war calls Jen seeds stupid calls Jen see
sensitive calls Jen see snowflakes calls
Jen seeds
jamesy okay boomer boomer meme rating
pretty good next name
[Music]
Paul Rudd ant-man AKA
ant-man the greatest Marvel hero of all
time when on hot ones and we have now
new meme template very funny when you
make next morning brunch plans when
you're hammered and then actually follow
through within us hey it's so wholesome
I love the music and everything
Hey look at it not me it's funny for
about two more memes I'll guarantee you
when you and your boo finally decide on
okay let's see how long this is still
funny
me and my friends drunkenly eating
McDonald's at 3m after one of us threw
up and one of us lost our ID and another
text of the Rex look at us Hey look at
us we had a rough night but we made it
through the end huh look at this who
would have thought okay one more
me at 7:00 p.m. guys I'm not going out
again for a while I can't afford it me
at 4:00 a.m. talking to myself in the
club bastard marriage look at us Hey
look at look at us Hey yeah I think it
stopped there I'm sorry my little
brother says and what my mom oh my god
don't say that my dad son that's awful
don't ever say that word my grandma look
at us I guess some generations can to
get along huh how about that the kids
who would've thought not me sorry I was
a joke it was a joke
okay Paul Rudd the meme not very epic
sorry it's wholesome but yeah next Hey
Oh Frick how did I forget its no not
November how are you doing how's it
going tell me you can now take the
pledge that if you jack off during no
not November you have to change your
avatar to the koomer are you man enough
to take on the challenge
you're Coomer bra pathetic forcing my
boyfriend to loose no not November on
the first day how dare you how dare you
some women don't understand oh look who
failed first day bra can't even make it
a day absolutely nobody absolutely
nothing people that past November people
that failed on that boom nobody em yeah
attention
did you fail no not November well little
did you know it's three strikes and
you're out
you're good bra here here what that's a
strike you can keep it for later don't
worry don't need to take me I do not
understand why nuts are forbidden for
one month are not good for health
she doesn't understand silly enemy girl
she doesn't understand the concept of
craving and how it never goes away and
really how it never makes us truly
satisfied so really it's all just based
on habits and any habit lasts around 30
days so if you stop you're free you can
be free I'm just gonna wear this I want
to buy it can you buy it
bra I gotta buy it do they still sell it
cuz I would like to buy it
sorry I'm Archie I'm going to bed good
night girl I see you tomorrow imagine
just walking around like this for a
whole month
happy epic all right I haven't seen that
many memes on and then and as the the
kids call it I don't know next oh I got
read it I read it Jesus Christ
he's looking always remember that next
means you've probably seen these type of
memes where when was earth discovered
around 4.54 billion years ago people for
20 million see falling in space get it
ha ha this meat was originated from an
older meme when was calcium discovered
1808 people in 1808 seven help I mean
this was good I like this one and then
now it spawns so many other ones when
was reddit created 2005 mods in 2004
because mods are apparently gay and
that's a running joke on reddit I'm just
explaining the joke when was h2o
discovered oh my god wait he lives
underwater that makes no sense this is
the worst when we're swords invented
people when we're microbes discovered
but look one of the microbes I don't get
it
the doorknob was invented 1878 all right
i'ma stay here so bad these are so bad
dude what was light invented oh look it
was dark before the light that's clever
I like that it's like did you know
before Isaac Newton discovered gravity
people would fly it's the same it's the
same joke but different format I it said
discovery not invention okay boomer
circular wheel was invented 3500 BC cars
before one was Wi-Fi invented oh great
you have a good meme format but these
memes sucked did slice bread was
invented in 1928 sandwiches before 1920
okay this one is epic sandwich time
travel only explanation it's the only
way we can wrap our mind around this
concept car invented okay this was
better in 1885 people before 1885 Wow
helium was discovered in 1868 the world
in 1867 down have you've seen that movie
it's pretty good when was Diamond
discovery come on goddamn so people were
really out there being poor but
for 1867 damn poles were invented 1840
people in 1939 all right okay I'm gonna
rate this meme not good but it has
potential just come up with something
funnier next me all right
so I'm starting a new segment on meme
review where we do some fun trivia in
facts here's one for you if you want
your house to smell like fall oil some
orange peels with half a teaspoon of
cinnamon on medium heat
I do this every fall and everyone loves
it and if steam didn't kill himself
that's pretty good here's another how to
eat candy corn you open the bag you pour
candy corn into trash can and then
Epstein didn't kill himself chance of a
lifetime for an epic trick SS worry move
equator international dateline the
passengers dreaming SS worry mu was
quietly knipfing his way through the
waters of the mid-pacific on its way
from Vancouver to Australia the
Navigator had just finished working out
the star fix and brought captain John
Diaz Phillips the result the Waring news
position was lat 0 degrees
31 north and long 179 30 West the date
was 39 SM Epstein was murdered to
protect the names of elitist pedophiles
who run the world that was really
interesting I never thought of that
alright one more the borough sir is a
wild pig whose Tuscan grows along the
curve backwards ultimately impaling
their skull and accidentally killing
them unlike those great this is what an
eagle looks like when you build a fire
inside the fire inside melts the inner
layer of ice and the cold outside
refreeze it adding a layer of insulation
that can keep the igloo at 60 degrees
inside while it's minus 50 outside and
Epstein didn't come on me thinking I'm
reading a cool new fun fact F scene
didn't kill himself so
they blue cheese is best some say ranch
dressing but deep dad we all know hummus
if savatya met damn it I thought the
finally we could all agree hummus is the
best dressing or is it sriracha mayo cuz
Rasha mayo is the bomb bruh it's much
like on this video
slifer's if you like sriracha mayo cuz
it's really good
some say xbox is the best some say
plasters and best everything not commit
bad FC memes gets a copy okay that was
it for this week there may be review
hope you guys enjoyed what we have time
for a bonus meme ok bonus memes
I bit my tongue so it's really hard to
speak today I hope but here you go find
those bonus meme to make up for it when
you say gracias Japanese restaurant wow
I feel like I've done this that's why
it's so funny okay that's it for me
review smash like check out merch check
out figuri check out bling blong check
up it buff Epstein mill flip flop epic
oh well you haven't tried to pursue me
later today after 50 million outros much
go just now it's still relevant just
down a bit